MARK MIRCHANDANI: Modernizing
traditional workflows requires
building Cloud First solutions.
Join us in historic
downtown Austin, Texas,
as we talk to SADA Systems
about their cloud architecture
and how they've built Atom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's talk about Atom.
What does the architecture
look like for Atom?
OLEG SHALYGIN: Atom's
architecture's very robust.
Everything is built on
Google Cloud Platform.
We're leveraging
Kubernetes engine
for all of the
different microservices,
and there's a various array
of portals within Atom.
Each portal may have three
or four various types
of microservices that
back that infrastructure.
It gives us the
flexibility of specifying
the right tool for the job,
which means we can say, hey,
this data is very relational,
very specific in the way
that it's laid out.
We can back that with
a CloudSQL database.
Whereas other data within
Atom is very non-relational
and dynamic based on
whoever the client may be
and what asset class they have.
So we can specify that
database to be a NoSQL solution
hosted on MongoDB Atlas.
Specifically, we
have dataflow jobs
where we pull data in from all
various DOTs that we work with
or different agencies, and
they have data today in there
as a reserver or
the ArcGIS server
that we pull from and then
real time display within Atom.
And so that whole
experience is more or less
seamless through
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what other
tools inside of Google Cloud
are you using?
OLEG SHALYGIN: So we use almost
the full gamut, specifically
around logging, tracing, a lot
towards developer productivity,
so that we can be
agile enough to respond
to the demands of the customer.
So we're pushing
code very regularly
on a weekly, almost
bi-weekly, basis.
And for us to be
able to do that, we
need the platform to do a
lot of the heavy lifting
in terms of automation,
in terms of security
best practices, the Command
Center, threat detection,
you name it.
We're leveraging the tools
to help boost developer
productivity.
And that's our big win on
Atom, is enabling everybody
on the team to be
comfortable with the platform
and proficient at
provisioning these services.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
you talked a little bit
about Kubernetes being
kind of the cornerstone
of a lot of this architecture.
Why Kubernetes?
OLEG SHALYGIN: So Kubernetes
gives us the availability
to scale based on demand, both
horizontally and vertically.
So we're not running
hundreds of hundreds of VMs
at 10% utilization.
We're able to utilize our
resources very effectively,
which ties directly
into the pricing models
that we offer these DOTs.
We can be very
competitive because we
are optimizing our consumption.
And so where that plays a big
role is we have periods of time
throughout the day where we
have a high amount of traffic
and load, specifically around
our download and offline
consumption.
So in the traditional
sense, somebody
will go out and perform
a bridge inspection.
Now, before they go
out, they realize, hey,
I'm not going to have cell
connectivity in this location.
So what they do is they
download everything
that they need to do on
the job, site and then
they work fully offline.
So when they regain
connectivity,
obviously, all of those updates
come back to the application.
We have a robust pipeline with
Pub/Sub and what have you,
but the actual
services themselves
need to scale very
rapidly to that demand.
Because, as you can
imagine, the end of the day
is when all of the inspectors
come back to their hotel rooms,
they regain
connectivity, and it's
eight plus hours worth
of work now getting
pushed over to our application.
So the ability to
respond to that demand
has been very
critical, and that's
the primary reason why we use
Kubernetes engine for that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So you mentioned
developer productivity earlier.
Has Google Cloud helped
you with making sure
that your developers are
more productive while working
on Atom?
OLEG SHALYGIN: Yeah, so
developer productivity
has drastically increased since
we've adopted Google Cloud
Platform and really started
leveraging the full gamut.
We can tie-in resources,
such as logging and tracing,
into these intuitive
dashboards that
can give a holistic
view of the application
to our development team.
We no longer need very
specialized resources
that specialize in
building these dashboards
or knowing some outside
tooling that they
can tie into a pipeline
or CI/CD environment.
Whereas, now our
developers can get back
to writing code quickly
and efficiently.
And that's essentially the
gamut of what we use today,
and we continue to use things
like Cloud Run to offload
some of our nightly jobs,
Crons, and what have you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
it sounds like Atom
was built with a
very Cloud-First
Architecture in mind.
When you are implementing
this, were there
any things that you wish were
different in Google Cloud?
OLEG SHALYGIN: Yeah, so when
we first started the product,
Identity Platform
wasn't a thing.
And now it is.
Ideally, we would like
to encompass everything
within Google Cloud Platform.
It gives us true visibility.
We don't need to go to numerous
systems and applications
to see where we stand
in terms of identity.
It would be ideal if it was
all within one platform, which
is what our goal has been.
So we use Okta today
and, ideally, we'd
be leveraging Identity Platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
thank you so much, Oleg,
for coming in and telling
us about how SADA built
these solutions in the cloud.
OLEG SHALYGIN: Thank you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for joining us,
and stay tuned for more customer
interviews on Stackchat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]